[موسيقى]
هذه فرصه فريده من نوعها تتاح لنا للتخلص
من العدد العسكري الذي يعود الى الحقبه
السوفيتيه والذي لا يزال موجودا لدينا
وربما يسمح لنا هذا الامر بتحقيق قفزه
نوعيه لكن برنامج تحديث القوات المسلحه في
بولندا هو برنامج ضخم ولدينا لائحه
مشتريات عسكريه ضخمه في الوقت الراهن
[موسيقى]
فان الدعم واسع النطاق الذي نقدمه
لاوكرانيا والذي شمل على سبيل المثال مدها
بنحو 300 دبابه يستوجب استبدال هذه
المعدات العسكريه باخرى جديده لذلك يتعين
علينا ان نبحث في اطار برنامج التحديث
الذي يخضع له جيشنا عن السبل الكفيله
بتمكيننا من الحصول على الذخائر والطائرات
والدبابات وغيرها من المعدات العسكريه
التي نزود اوكرانيا بها
[موسيقى]
هولندا تقع كذلك على حدود بلد تعرض للهجوم
وهي البلد الاوروبي الوحيد الذي يعيش في
هذه البيئه الجغرافيه وبولندا لديها ايضا
بلد جار صعب للغايه لذلك ينبغي ان نبذل
قصار جهودنا من اجل تحسين اوضاعنا الامنيه
[موسيقى]
لكن الحرب التي تدور راحها في جوارنا
تتسبب في تسريع الكثير من البرامج
الدفاعيه لدينا ويسري هذا التسريع على شتى
المجالات وبكل بساطه ليس لدينا الوقت الذي
يسمح لنا بتبني نهج يتسم بالبطء بغيه بلوغ
اهدافنا في ظل استمرار هذه الحرب التي
تجعلنا نسرع الخطى حتى نكون جاهزين
لمواجهه الاوضاع الصعبه السائده
[موسيقى]